prank your ex-husbands and your current
husband in order from best to worse in
bed
so I don't like to talk about my men
because then you're all going to want to
come
number one is Todd number two would be
the dad okay and number three would have
been Herman
[Applause]
would you marry kill or bang shabang
Monique Samuels I would bang her to
death
[Music]
Giselle we are with women here would
make the least on only fans that's an
easy question I was gonna say Marisol
only because you wouldn't understand it
who doesn't want these little Honeys
rubbing the soot off your papaya this is
a money maker next up we
definitely think
Embers from season 13 of Real Housewives
of New York should not be asked to come
back for the Legacy spin-off that
they're going to do
[Music]
by the way that's a big deal because
she's very picky with her food she's a
vegan or a kosher
you're a soldier girl
really yeah I'm really not you have no
thoughts I don't I don't do casting I
don't do firing I don't do hiring I
don't do any of it well I don't either
but you know Giselle should go Whitney
yes I'm gonna need you to name three
times
they have it a lot on camera
[Music]
let's bring it right now oh I'm
seriously this is good
what is between Heather and I I want to
talk to her oh I don't want to be messy
no more I want to talk to Heather
well that's mature hand clap for you
food for the game
eating this scorpion is me showing
Heather that I'm still trying to be her
friend you have had every opportunity to
say all the times I've lied and you've
been able to come up with one imaginary
lie so you've already played this game
and you lost pick a lane be a villain be
a friend be something but be real
this is both
next up will be Heather Heather's
question is who gave you the black eye
okay she's gonna eat the Scorpion
you know what's so funny you said you
didn't know so you must know no we I we
know that she knows she thinks Jen did
it who thinks Jen did it I do oh yeah me
too oh I think she's protecting Jen
Whitney must know she must know that I
went to Jen's room and I said Jen I am
the informant and Jen said oh hell no
and just spot me there's only a couple
reasons why Heather would go out of her
way to protect Jen like this either Jen
has something major over Heather or like
attracts like
this is nothing that you're gonna
uncover Nancy Drew so next up miss
beautiful Marisol tell me tell me tell
me what he got in this group who
do you
dress the least
good question that's a good one yeah
well that's easy you because you've
thrown me under the bus three times
already
you know things like that dinner well
like you drink too much and I thought
that was you know a little hypocritical
because you used to drink a lot
because your stomach hurts don't take it
out on me Leah that's not fair it's not
my fault that you're drinking vodka
every morning
that's my answer
[__] I don't trust you either so it's
all good